yes
[Music]
so
here's a it's not a trick it's just
sound
body mechanics okay so uh when i
when my hand gets gripped this way this
is a step behind the start of the
technique
so he grips really hard and i'm not
going to get her around the outside of
that hand
in any kind of mechanically sound way
okay you can't do it energetically
but why not combine my energetic
engines with my mechanical engines so
what you do is inside the grip this way
for soto so again not here
this would be for uchi
and it's a timing thing so i don't go
like this and then try to do it
i don't sit here like this and give it
to him it's a timing thing which is why
most people can't see it and they don't
do it
so whoa pop so we go on with the
technique
and the same thing on the hand turn and
that will give you the
sultan opening if you want to pay
attention on the hat
boom
he's still
[Music]
don't change the wrist bring the arm out
though it makes no sense
to bring the arm out and you're trying
to get in
so you don't bring the arm out on social
womb
here straightening
you go out like this now you got to
bring it that arm that you were trying
to bring in you got to bring it in
after you brought it out so soto comes
straight in
boom
in
[Music]
adjust it
so you're doing the same spiral i won't
do the arm change and i'm doing the same
spiral
this way
so i'm here won't there's content that's
coming
but when i go to the outside by giving
the other
soto home
no opening and then in
opening in
okay okay so i'm doing all that and what
i'm really doing here
is getting this hat to go into shihan
nugget
so one two oh there it is
and so how do you how do you do it is
you're going to lift up start to move
across his body
boom and now when you tank on you'll be
in it
so make sure that that's your goal and
you're not doing some weird thing like
this
because that's when the person does not
uh they sometimes turn
under you so you're going like this and
they won't
they keep turning like this on you
you're going like this and they keep
turning like
so your only goal is when you come up
here go down
and the person that turns like that ends
up on the wrong side of the back right
that's their fault okay but when you
close this
off boom you're there that's that's your
main goal
and into it
then like all things find his center
center's right here
go ahead center so i'm not pulling down
i was just showing you to pull down
so that i get them to stop turning
around like that
okay around hold here now when you're
here
you're in his center
you're not just pulling his arm down
[Music]
close and then his center okay